dans cette période de reprise économique
les appels pour une relance verte se
multiplient chez emmanuel macron n'a pas
dit autre chose dimanche déclarant que
la reconstruction devait être social
solidaire et écologique
le confinement a drastiquement réduit la
consommation d'énergie les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre à la pollution
mais la relance de l'économie française
laisse supposer un retour au niveau que
nous avons connu par le passé c'est le
thème de la chronique ce matin de notre
éditorialiste économique jean marc
sylvestre
bonjour jean marc travailler plus dire
emmanuel macron mais ceux qui
travaillent veulent gagner plus c'est le
cas notamment des personnels soignants
qui manifestaient donc hier beaucoup
aussi aspirent à travailler autrement
certaines contre une contradiction
risque donc d'être difficile à lever
oui ça va être assez compliqué à gérer
parce que le président assis réjouit
évidemment de la victoire gagnée sur le
virus mais il doit effectivement
maintenant affronter tous ceux qui
attaquent la façon dont il a géré cette
crise
le bilan de la crise et ceux qui ne
comprennent pas comment il va sortir
l'économie du piège dans lequel elle est
tombée il va devoir bien sûr ça c'est un
premier point mais il a déjà commencé à
le faire a tiré les leçons de tous les
dysfonctionnements qu'il ya eu au début
de cette crise avec le manque de masques
de test la cacophonie de conseils
médicaux d'abîmer deuxième fois plus
politique il va falloir justifier les
choix d'un confinement très strictes
certes pour vaincre le virus mais c'est
un confinement qui a été acquis au prix
d'un arrêt presque totale de l'économie
alors vous allez me dire il n'avait pas
tellement le choix
tous là tous les pays ont fait un peu
près la même chose c'est d'ailleurs ce
que vient de recommencer à faire pékin
avec la reprise de pandémie mais il ya
quand même beaucoup de dégâts que l'on
sait au niveau de l'entreprise avoir des
difficultés à régler il ya beaucoup de
patrons aujourd'hui qui se demandent si
la pandémie valait peut-être la peine de
tomber dans ce type de catastrophe d'où
les loisirs de relance et de soutien
pour éviter l effondrement
oui alors bien sûr sauf que là encore on
est en pleine contradiction sur le
modèle de développement à mettre en
place
d'un côté vous avez tous ceux qui
considèrent que la vie économique et
sociale doit reprendre son train
d'évolution qui est marqué par une
croissance par un progrès si possible au
bénéfice du plus grand nombre c'est
d'ailleurs le message de beaucoup de
manifestants les gens de la régie
renault la semaine dernière faisait
porter ce message mais les personnels
soignants d'un côté veulent aussi des
efforts quantitatif en termes
budgétaires mais de l'autre de l'autre
vous avez tous ceux qui pensent que
cette épidémie catastrophe est le
résultat de la mondialisation c'est le
résultat d'un système de capitalisme
financier et sans doute du réchauffement
climatique même tout cela pense que
l'occasion est donc forte pour faire
évoluer le modèle avec un peu moins de
croissance moins de co2 moins d'énergies
fossiles alors entre ces deux bases là
et bien acquis sont apparemment
contradictoires le président de la
république est complètement coincé quand
même
il annonce le retour à la vie normale et
par exemple la libre circulation
aérienne qui sera sans doute rétabli au
niveau international dès la fin du mois
mais en même temps il prophétise un
monde nouveau un monde différent un
monde plus calmes un monde plus vert
bref il parle non plus aux chefs
d'entreprise actuel mais qui attendent
ça depuis deux mois ou même aux salariés
mais il pas à tous les amis de brita
sundberg à même ce nicolas hulot qui
sont très nombreux en france et qui
explique que le modèle de croissance
productiviste mais là n'est plus le bon
il va falloir arrêter des voyages en
avion par exemple il va falloir croître
moins vite se soigne et peut-être avec
une autre médecine peut-être plus
naturel je sais pas si vous avez noté
par exemple dans le confinement est bien
la france a arrêté par exemple de faire
vacciner même ses enfants et c'est une
tendance alors bien sûr il y avait des
difficultés à l'hôpital mais il ya aussi
une grande partie de la france qui est
dans cette médecine la partisans d'une
médecine plus douces plus naturelles les
deux modèles là sont difficilement
compatibles merkel répond c'est ce qu'on
peut apporter sans hypothéquer la
croissance à ce qui est de nos pieds
défendre le climat
c'est tout le problème de chefs
d'entreprise ils savent aussi qu'il leur
faudra évoluer ils le savent très bien
et pour répondre à leurs salariés leurs
clients leurs actionnaires qu'ils ont
tous à peu près la même revendication
qui veulent une croissance plus verte
plus meilleur parce qu'ils savent très
bien qu au bout bah c'est quand même un
risque et c'est dangereux
ils savent que c'est possible tout en
produisant de la richesse et en créant
des
d'emplois mais les chefs d'entreprise
ont besoin de savoir très clairement sur
la paire l'état et sa l'état doit
l'annoncer le président de la république
doit l'annoncer début juillet ceux qui
construisent des automobiles ont besoin
de vendre dans les pays émergents il
faut qu'il continue parce que la
croissance
elle est dans les pays émergents ce donc
pas question de renault qu'alizé tous à
ceux qui sont dans le tourisme et qui
sont les premiers employeurs de france
veulent savoir comment faire tourner
leurs établissements s'il n'y a pas de
touristes étrangers
et puis les soignants bas vous les avez
entendus ils veulent avoir les moyens de
vivre correctement
si le seul moyen de protéger
l'environnement de lutter contre le
climat c'est de freiner la croissance en
faisant de la morale vous savez on n'est
pas sorti de l'auberge
merci beaucoup c'est l ai dit au micro
de jean-marc semestre